el número de bajas entre el ejército
ucraniano está aumentando los últimos
días ya lo viste lenski y es que en el
frente del don base las tropas rusas
están utilizando cada vez más artillería
y en severo nese y es lobby anses donde
se estaban produciendo el mayor número
de bajas en este contexto la presidenta
de la comisión europea o sólo venderle
yen ha visitado y que se ha reunido con
el esquí e incluso ha visitado también a
varios militares heridos que están
hospitalizados en centros aquí en la
capital dice ursula von der leyen que la
próxima semana la unión europea dará una
respuesta sobre la entrada de ucrania en
la unión europea algo que desde aquí las
autoridades se toman con bastante
escepticismo porque llevan pidiendo esa
entrada en la unión europea desde que
empezó la guerra hace más de 100 días no
sólo eso también la exportación de grano
de cereal
francia se ha propuesto para mediar y
para poder desbloquear esos puertos que
están bloqueados por el ejército
y es que recordemos que rusia controla
ya el 20% del territorio ucraniano e
incluso ha empezado a dar ya pasaportes
rusos en zonas ocupadas como gerson y
melito